mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos wünschen ihnen viel vergnügen
vielzahl und vielfalt beeindrucken
mehrere dutzend künstlerinnen und
künstler haben sich an kulturplatz
wettbewerb beteiligt zusammen mit dem
publikum kürt eine prominente jury die
lieblingsprojekte die vier punktbesten
porträtieren wir ab nächster woche
fortlaufend in unserem programm
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kurplatz ja wir
machen heute in luzern station und hier
im kunstmuseum wird eine hochkarätige
jury für uns hirnen
[Musik]
denn kultur schaffen der die wegen
corona in bedrängnis geraten sind
konnten sich bei uns melden mit der
chance für einen auftritt und wer das
sein wird das wird heute entschieden
unsere idee ist eine von vielfältigen
programm schwerpunkten von sf und kultur
schaffen der zu unterstützen
unter dem motto zusammen
[Musik]
die gastgeber den hüter und kunstmuseum
luzern ist direktorin auch sie ist als
jurymitglied schaue ich was bedeutet
ihnen der prozess vom schiri aber sie
sind sich was wir können
ich bin mir tatsächlich sehr die
ausstellung bereits am nächsten
wochenende eröffnet das ist schiri die
ausstellung aber eigentlich bin ich ganz
allein und ständig macht dann ist das ja
auch irgendwie jährige wissen berührt
und muss mir überlegen was interessiert
es aber andere menschen wie kann man das
kontextualisiert vermittler sind gleich
die frage stellen wer größere schäden
hat zusammen mit der ferne beurteilen
wie die persönlichkeiten schweizer
kultur schaffen
die arbeiter anatoli bekannt wurde sie
mitte der 1990 er als vreni in der
sitcom fasste familie
gut so heraus sagt seit jahren ist die
theater und filmschauspielerin auch als
regisseurin tätig 2014 übernahm sich
zudem die leitung des bernhard theaters
in zürich egal ob auf oder hinter der
bühne
die aargauerin fühlt sich in
unterschiedlichsten rollen zu hause
pedro lenz der mundart schriftsteller
dichter cologne ist wird für sein
schaffen regelmäßig ausgezeichnet sich
selbst beschreibt der gebürtige
langenthaler als intellektuellen mit
glitzer herz seine geschichten sind
tiefgründig komisch liebenswert
menschlich der kolibri sein erster roman
wurde fürs kino adaptiert das drehbuch
erhielt 2014 den schweizer filmpreis
eben erschienen sein neuestes werk
primitivo
und bereits kennengelernt fanny fetzer
direktorin des kunstmuseums luzern
sie wollte künstlerin werden studierte
aber nach dem vorkurs an der
kunstgewerbeschule in zürich politik
wissenschaft gesellschaft und kunst
fetzer arbeitete beim kulturmagazin du
und führte das kunsthaus langenthal
bevor sie von neun jahren die leitung in
luzern übernahmen bei der ausstellungs
planung setzt sie großen wert auf ein
ausgeglichenes geschlechterverhältnis
[Musik]
und das immer mit der jury drei personen
schüler eigentlich wäre es 47 habe ich
mit das tesla chef mit der sängerin
sie ist leider krank sie fällt uns gut
die bessere hälfte die andere sind da
das sind rolle in luzern auch jetzt sind
die real oft auf der bühne oder
ausstellen oder sind hier wo sich zeigen
wie vertraut sind
ich glaube das ist krieg mit der armee
hat zum morgen passt oder nicht will ich
das tue ich mir nicht einfach sagen ich
hab es berührt mich ist ganz gut über
hiermit schlecht machen aber von dort in
ruhe zu lassen
dort sagen das ist gute projekte sowie
mehr umgekehrt was ich sage das will
oder das bett mit dem dicken empfehlen
sehr ruhige
über 60 zusendungen sind bei uns
eingetroffen
daraus haben wir zehn projekte
vorausgewählt diese einsendungen legen
wir nun der jury vor
jedes jurymitglied verteilt punkte
darüber hinaus hat auch das publikum
eine stimme es war wir online voting
beteiligt die vier am besten bewerteten
projekte stellen wir ihnen ab nächste
sendung wöchentlich vor
und hier zeigen wir ihnen jetzt die
ersten projekte die wir in kurzen videos
für sie aufbereitet haben das material
übrigens das stammt von den wettbewerb
teilnehmenden selbst vor fünf jahren
veröffentlichte andreas forster sein
erstes album seither sehen jetzt der
mundartsänger aus zürich wiedikon über
die gesellschaft und den irrsinn dieser
weg mit poesie und witz
[Musik]
sein motto trotz unerklärlichem
verhalten humor behalten auch in
schwierigen lebenslagen des fußballs
2020 schrieben
und der wirtschaft zeit wurde das vieh
zu wenn sie also chor und gemerkt das
ist die santix sieht vor dass 2020 musik
und twitter kann
[Musik]
blieb
das sind die illustratorin sophie
benvenuti unter künstler felix stöcklin
in ihrem siebdruck atelier torino press
arbeiten die beiden oft mit plakaten
etwa zu sexistischer werbung da es
corona bedingt schwierig geworden ist
die eigenen werke sichtbar zu machen
haben sie eine besondere idee entwickelt
war nicht den öffentlichen raum mit
kunst bescheiden zb ein plakat säule
dieses projekt bringt wunsch der
menschen nach aevo besetzt wenig
berührungspunkte mit der kulturkreis ein
jahr lang möchten sie künstlerinnen und
künstlern aus der ganzen schweiz
ermöglichen an plakat säulen in st
gallen wäre oder biel auszustellen
so sollen sich auch die kulturszene in
der deutschschweiz und der romandie
näher kommen
[Musik]
der klingende adventskalender bis
heiligabend öffnet das stradivari
quartett aus zürich täglich ein türchen
dahinter verbergen sich 24 musikalische
überraschungen
jede wird in einem anderen schweizer
hotel gelüftet aber anrufe befreundet
die musiker schweiz vehement und jeden
tag das konzert für rosi zuschauer
spielt maria weber stradivari advent
wenn emotionen schenken in
herausfordernden zeiten den konzerten
kann man vor ort oder per stream
beiwohnen
es gibt eine kollekte
und einen schulterschluss kultur und
hotellerie beide von der korona krise
gebeutelt unterstützen sich gegenseitig
[Musik]
natürlich zum ist jedes projekt kurz
würdige miteinander also wenn ihr jetzt
an die fcc wenn ihr jetzt das kurze
video ärger denn hat mir eigentlich
gefallen dass er das schüttere oder die
schwierige situation jetzt mit krone
kontextualisiert lustigen art von humor
romano ohne die genauso sagte ja das ist
mir die these dass ich meine chance
jetzt geht mit der drahtlosen ich denke
dass im umgang mit mit mit themen wie
finde ich sehr erfrischend das nächste
projekt alias turbo presse
sie wird eine bis macher wo sie das
selber promoten und sondern sie bieten
den anderen liegt wiederum zur verfügung
stelle also es ist ein multiplikator wo
sie schaffen und das bin ich total
schöne gesten heutige zeit wo man sich
am us distanzieren soll dabei bliebe
und sie schaffen irgendwie möglichkeit
wie es doch wie diese geltende neue
sichtbarkeit erreicht mir hat er sehr
überzeugt von mir was sie machen mit der
barkasse jetzt wahnsinnig habe sich
weiter aus für urheberrecht vor
das dritte projekt der stradivari
quartett das finde ich sehr schön aber
so als idee ist wie er nach dass man
wieso es geschenke geht also das land
thüringen macht ganz neue idee die
musikalische adventskalender gibt es
überall
das imk was in kombination mit schönen
hotel das für attraktiv also dass wir
jetzt mit einem projekt ist das mein
geld und mehr
dominik reisig oder die konzerte
abgesagt und die hochachtung für leute
mit wenig oder sogar defizite die wir
euch einfach so haben auch einfach sag'
ich mich um ca das ist nur die alte
socke schnur erzählt gerne tier
geschichten für kinder
doch es hat ihm die sprache verschlagen
deshalb müssen die beiden musikerinnen
martina stutz und anna boss tilly für
ihn einspringen
[Musik]
die helligkeit von filmen musik studiert
denn erst einmal im kindergarten
ausprobieren und das haben die letzten
acht
und mit zwei eigenes zwei etwa das lied
über den stier wieder bewegen einer
kreativen blockade wieder aufs land
zieht
[Musik]
momentan kann schnee kaum auftreten
dabei würde er doch so gerne
[Musik]
das panoramabild port kreierte stephan
brühl hardware des schatten im kunstraum
kultur hunger in bruck fahrt besteht aus
72 unikaten jeder künstler ab dem 13
dezember im atelier und im internet
verkauft
die zwischen signiert solle die nahrung
220 cm überfliegen warnt das
quadratische formate lauterer spieler
mit komplexen beziehung
ich bin so der erlös kommt
kulturschaffenden zugute später soll die
soziale skulptur zu einem stück
erinnerungskultur werden zwei neue bild
was ich danach 27 sportart kunst zum
partizipieren und diskutieren
[Musik]
der tanzstil von miriam bake ist eine
eigenkreation die tänzerin und
choreografin aus zürich verbindet
elemente aus ost und west
persönlich wünschte fusion von denen
2000 stil
es ist auch ins chinesische tanz stil zu
große einfluss hat aus bewegung und
folklore tanz aus nordafrika und naher
osten
die inspiration dafür findet miriam
baraka seit jahren in gemeinsamen
auftritten mit gleichgesinnten aus
palästina heuer aber brach ein projekt
weg da die grenzen plötzlich geschlossen
waren
[Musik]
felix vermerk bt und demonstrierte
wurden im himmel mit umso mehr möchte
maria baraka in diesen zeiten auf der
bühne brücken schlagen zwischen den
unterschiedlichen tanz kulturen
hamster im rad kommt samstagmittag kommt
nach uns davon verbitte darfst du auch
ein tiea oder bist du schon salat
die baseler band will unkraut verbindet
spoken word mit musik und greift mit
diesem mix absurditäten des lebens auf
sie genossen für die hat sich seit der
sendung grafik stressig sagt du kannst
auf twitter kochen ganz ruhig sein
hier müsse zu
ich will und brauche statt schreibt uns
[Musik]
ratlos
das trio gibt es erst seit ende 2009 10
wegen corona konnte es erst einmal
öffentlich auftreten ganz genau das ist
die zweite runde als erstes besprechen
wir das projekt der schnur und sie mit
ihren säuglingen und weiß es wichtig
dass eine geschichte zu zeigen und wie
wichtig diese inhaltlich wichtig sie
eine tiergeschichte sie und somit später
auf die kindliche erteilt also mir sehr
schnell auffällt oder weniger schlimm
sind nämlich nie und ich kann ihn mir
denn mich so wieder wie zu erinnern was
ich wirklich das wort kinder richtig
spaß
ich finde die fusion was sie machen und
probiere ich sehr lässig das nächste
projekt
port des künstlers stephan brühl
mit dem projekt park geht es zwei
aspekte mir sehr gut gefallen ein wenig
das ist uns teile gott wie schon titel
vor dem projekt kultur wird und andere
ist dass er selber seit die künstler die
quadrat die haben hier die richtigen
geholt ich habe dem format spieler die
kein oben und kann muss ich sagen es ist
ein mittel aber natürlich für junge
menschen junge kunst für dynamik
wenn es richtig im kopf ausstoß um 60
junge und darum mit etlichen die tüten
was mir vor allem projekte ich dass mir
seit ich fünf jahre nur gemüter und das
geht so bis auf dass ich fünf jahre
locker mit einem druck auf die korona
finden und das geht mir hört es kurz
gefehlt
miriam baraka und ihr tanzprojekt
zwischen westlicher und östlicher welt
ist das nächste projekt im wettbewerb
mit wahnsinnig die fusion wo sie macht
aus dem orientalisch das wofür mich sehr
so sehr wie üblich ist und der
umtriebigkeit gott und das was jetzt
macht ist für mich irgendwie gott so
eine bin ich nämlich auch weibliche oder
männliche juden sondern sehr kraftvoll
und und und das berührt mich ein orden
mir sind auch das ziel bisher
eigenständig entwickelt wurde jetzt
einfach nur statische blick auf
traditionelle orientalische tanz sondern
dass sie die herkunft oder die
verschiedene welten in denen sie sich
bewegt in ihrem tanz wicklungen
verbinden
das trainiert bis auf eine konstante
oder wissen schon salat dill und kraut
spoken word projekt ausbauen
also mir natürlich schon der name vor
der reformation diehl und kraut das hat
eine ehrlichkeit und der humor und der
scharfsinnige der musikhalle befindet
versteigert arbeite gerade an einen
auftritt vor der einigung
also sie handlich mit dem alltag die
poesie und den namen ständig mit dem mit
ihrer körperlichkeit ganz schrecklich
also die wird so verloren sony
interessiert der literatur ist
willkommen so gut mit musik verbinden
dass das passt das begeistere mich
richtig die dritte und letzte um nehmen
das konzert auf ihrer geplant ein
programm mit musik aus shakespeares
tagen das ensemble macht melodien aus
längst vergangener zeit mit historischen
instrumenten wieder lebendig
absolventinnen und absolventen der
weltweit anerkannten schola cantorum
basiliensis haben das concerto scirocco
vor zehn jahren gegründet es ist auf
musik aus der renaissance und des
frühbarock spezialisiert bestimmt das
einzige junge an formel mit sitz in pcs
sich insbesondere mit diese wunderbare
epoche der musikgeschichte
auseinanderfällt
die jüngst geplante reise in die
vergangenheit soll bald in eine
fantasievolle welt wie aus shakespeares
feder entführen
sie schaut toll das ist junge menschen
sind wo die alte musik spielen oder so
und ich hatte viel mit dem sich nicht
einfach nur dass eltern oder
traditionelles publikum für klassische
musik wenden
mir persönlich gefällt die musik sehr
finde das hat auch sehr viel heiterkeit
mehr gespielt und alle tanzschritte
gehen weil ich dann jedes programm
lockte mich das sehr ambitioniert dass
ich das richtig großes konzert wo sie
davon was wir wirklich druck machten mit
wie sowas auch aber sp klassischer musik
speziell ist die bütt wurde ich will
dass meine haare sondern harmonie heute
bringt und die sagen das zusammenspiel
ich finde dass ich hätte nicht etwas mit
ihrer musik nicht vergessen die
ex-freundinnen während in partylaune und
[Musik]
rock'n'roll würde corona ihnen nicht
einen strich durch die rechnung machen
ende oktober feierte sie kommen die
gruppe mit neuem programm premiere
doch diese blieb zugleich die vorläufig
letzte show
inspiriert von den irrungen und
wirrungen dieser zeit wünschen sich
martina lori aniko donath und dieser
reflex mal nichts lieber als ein happy
end aber dafür dass bei der sekte statt
sekt die satire gerinnen lassen es
knallen
schlimmer geht immer
[Musik]
dass man jetzt sehr vorne ex freundin
das wirkte sich das ist wirklich
gutgemacht comedians wo sie sind oder
man sich sagt rolf demuth und das mit
der exzellenten mit einem augenzwinkern
natürlich auch immer machen
ich habe große hochachtung vor reden
bundes ganzkörper skelett kostüm das
hätte ich angehöre
dank verschiedener zum letzten sie
bringen klänge aus der ganzen welt in
schweizer schulzimmer sascha eine
multikulturelle gruppe um christian vock
ihre lieder in über zehn verschiedenen
sprachen singen und spielen sie
gemeinsam zu bespannt sind natürlich
auftritt die schule und relativen hoch
russland rat teile
wir haben ist schon mal begrüßen ihre
sprache oder dobro dann fühlen sich die
auch ganz anders gesprochen
mit hilfe von vertrauten klängen kommen
auch schüchterne kinder aus sich heraus
dass ich aus wo ist denn die kraft geht
das ganze über jahre schon wieder zu
machen
wir hatten schon wird über die konzerte
führungen zur projekttag und ich freue
mich wirklich auf jede einzelne person
ist auch endlich wollen ganz ganz zurück
bis auf weiteres sind solche begegnungen
aber höchstens eingeschränkt möglich
also was sie bedrückt finden wenn ich
das sehe auf video
foto nur geben wenn die musiziert was da
die die kultur jetzt dass die späne sehr
zäh die die kraftlose bitte finden
es ist natürlich sehr und pädagogischer
ansatz musiker hans also beim letzten
kunstprojekt roboter serie pädagogik
einer was sie machen das braucht so
wenig zum miteinander über kulturen oder
über verschiedene herkunft könne aus
dusche ob das noch in eine musikalische
interessante dem lauf eine workshop das
weiß ich nicht so gut aber als geste
finde ich total schön es ist ja ist ein
angler kulturaustausches gute schule ist
die matura mit einer
wettbewerbsteilnahmen der jury zieht
sich zurück zu entscheidenden beratungen
im luzern nach nabel thema sport
[Musik]
sie hatte und von weeze aus gastgeberin
ist die sprache in valley resultaten wie
ja interessant ist oder dass mir drei
aus so unterschiedlichen bereichen zu
andere erfahrungen
aber ist denn doch recht einig geworden
sind sehr schnell was diese meister
interessiert und was mir jetzt echt in
dem zehn mal weniger wichtig finden
ich fange maschinen mit einem auf dem
dritter oder vierter platz zwei mit
genau 28
einer sitzt das concerto scirocco und
miriam baracke
denn heimat auf dem zweiten platz
das projekt mit dem plakat in der
öffentlichkeit die pop press heißt das
auf dem ersten platz
ich finde es ganz klar die und kraut
gesehen
jetzt haben wir das resultat vom
publikum als auch quasi vom vierte
mitglied und taxameter gunst von
publikum und scirocco 12 stradivari
advent an dritter stelle und an vierter
stelle an die f und auf gesamtzahl
gesamtbewertung von der anwesen der jury
hat das noch einfluss die hand des an
resultat vor dem wettbewerb und das
heißt miriam barak auf platz vier
der zweite rang ärgert sich concerto
scirocco und der erste platz geht an den
und cams gratulation
ich finde es ist jetzt schon ganz genau
gleich ist es fertig wieder aus vor der
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer aber der
abstieg wies die über medizin ihre
inszenierung und das mit einem stil und
kraut so ein können einiges ist erst die
platz ist das spricht sehr für die
position und ich freue mich auf denen
ihre betrag ganz herzlich danken dem
wettbewerb
sie haben es gehört unser wettbewerb
geht in eine zweite runde
wenn sie also kunstschaffende sind und
ihr projekt liegt wegen corona in der
schublade dann melden sie sich
einsendeschluss für die zweite tranche
ist er neunter dezember und in der
nächsten sendung dann sagen wir ihnen
das erste projekt des wettbewerbs das
erste siegel projekt ausführlich dann
geht es bei uns auch um die liebe gleich
jetzt folgt eine neue schweizer serie
unter dem titel ohne grenzen kommen sie
gut durch die woche im sinne von
hammerstein
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]